she got a big day coming up in august do
i do man I'm getting married Kevin Hart
will soon tie the knot with fiance eniko
parish and et chatted with the comedian
about his bride-to-be at the New York
premiere of the secret life of pets on
Saturday my fiancé is actually on her
Bachelorette like trip right now yeah
are you nervous Charlie checking in
careless meanwhile Kevin's fiance is
enjoying a tropical getaway in the
Dominican Republic sharing sexy
Instagram photos with her wedding squad
using the hashtag Don't Tell heart
where's your bachelor that's a good see
that that's why I could care less but
you don't ask questions I mean you can't
ask me questions about mine that's it
I'm out I'm going somewhere I don't know
what I'm doing yet i'm so excited to do
absolutely nothing probably the 36 year
old comedian stayed tight-lipped on his
party plans but had an adorable response
for what he wants an eco to get him for
his upcoming birthday on july six you
know you that's it see that look at
those brownie points that's the biggest
birthday gifted one nothing else and
leave it to Kevin to also find the humor
in getting older we saw you on snapchat
the other day dyeing your hair yes we've
created a glass I'm turning into Morgan
Freeman I don't know what's going on I
think and my older age is just going
straight to my hair it goes completely
great
you